maybe i'm reading too much into it since  you told us he had exams this morning  but he does look more tired to me than  than usual well ding he just caught a  fly with his bare hands  out of the air did he yeah oh i missed  it i blinked i missed it  he's looking if it's still there oh  that's his superpower there you are  it's an important skill for chess  players i'm sure  you've heard the story about who was it  rubinstein who was followed around by  the same flight for years like he would  train take a train  from prague to munich and the fly would  just jump on the train and still be  there with him when he arrived wow so  catching flies is a very important skill  for chess players  or keeping your mental sanity but if you  can't do that